[Musique]
la déchirure supérieur du cratère de
l'etna eugène viollet le duc le grimp en
1836 et l'immortaliser par le travail
sur la couleur est absolument
exceptionnelle tout en restant d'une
précision extrême par rapport aux
paysages qu'il a devant les yeux
on est vraiment à la fois dans une
saisie sur le vif et en même temps dans
un relevé qui est du cas chatoiement
québec et d'un cas d'une préciosité
extraordinaire celui que l'on connaît
architecte était un voyageur passionné
de montagne une part de sa vie mise en
lumière au musée lambinet dans sa
nouvelle exposition elle est claire
exceptionnellement la totalité de sa
pratique et notamment celles
d'architectes donc ça nous a semblé
extrêmement important d'autant que s'il
faut pas oublier que ces dessins sont
exceptionnelles par leurs qualités
propres
donc rien pour le plaisir de dieu
c'était important de faire des mettre en
valeur mais effectivement il était
intéressant de les situer de les
resituer dans l'intégralité du travail
d'un personnage aussi important pour
pour l'architecturé française des
dessins de montagne poursuivre
l'architecte dans son cheminement dans
sa pratique du paysage des dessins à la
technique légère car pris sur le vif le
crayon se mêle à la gouache l'aquarelle
[Musique]
un autodidacte qui se forme sur le
terrain qui pratiquent très tôt et très
tôt initié au dessin sur le motif et
pour lequel le dessin est véritablement
l'ossature temps de sa formation que sa
pratique tout au long de sa vie eugène
viollet le duc laisse derrière lui plus
de 450 dessins 31 d'entre eux sont à
découvrir à versailles
[Musique]